willkommen an der theresianischen
militärakademie in wiener neustadt ich
bin oberst markus reisen ich bin der
leiter der forschungs
entwicklungsabteilung und heute wollen
wir uns in einem neuen video den
sachstand betreffend der lieferung von
schweren waffen in die ukraine ansehen
das erste das wichtig ist zu verstehen
ist dass wenn der streitkräfte
erfolgreich einen konflikt bestehen
wollen müssen sie über verschiedene
fähigkeiten verfügen diese fähigkeiten
kann man im teilbereich unterteilen ich
nehme jetzt hier am beispiel drei heraus
einerseits die fähigkeit zur führung die
fähigkeit effektive aufklärung zu
betreiben aber natürlich auch die
fähigkeit zum angriff nur wenn all diese
fähigkeiten erfüllt sind können sie den
konflikt für sich entscheiden wenn das
nicht der fall ist werden sie diesen
konflikt verlieren wenn wir uns nun die
ukrainischen streitkräfte ansehen zu
sehen wir dass all diese fähigkeiten in
den einzelnen teilstreitkräften
abgebildet sind heute wollen wir uns im
speziellen die landstreitkräfte ansehen
und das was ein gerät dort verfügbar ist
beziehungsweise ob dieses gerät
zusätzlich durch die waffenlieferungen
entsprechend verstärkt werden konnte
die ukrainische landstreitkräfte
befinden sich über die gesamte ukraine
verteilt natürlich mit schwergewicht
dort wo die kämpfe stattfinden also im
raum den bass der hartz iv aber
natürlich auch hier entlang dieser
langen vorgänger von person bis zappa
roche
wenn wir uns das gerät ansehen dass die
ukrainische streitkräften 24 februar
verfügbar hatten so können wir anhand
von drei beispielen sehen dass die
ukrainischen streitkräfte sehr potent
aufgestellt waren sie verfügten über
knapp 2.400 panzer und gepanzerte
fahrzeuge über 1500 artilleriegeschütze
und mörser und über 500 mehrfach
raketenwerfer
diese einzelnen gerätschaften waren
gegliedert in verschiedenen brigaden die
brigaden sind quasi die kernelemente des
gefechts mit dem die ukraine versucht
nun die russischen und chinesischen
angriffe abzuwehren
diese brigaden kann man wie folgt
ansprechen die ukraine verfügt über die
bircks brigaden motorisierte brigaden
mechanisierte begaben panzerbrigade
naber hat die brigaden am beispiel der
panzerbrigade sehen wir dass die ukraine
am 24 februar
bei aktive band zu begeben hatte und
vier in reserve sowie ein
selbstständiges panzerbataillon damit
diese brigaden ihre fähigkeiten
entwickeln können brauchen sie
unterstützungskräfte die wir hier links
und rechts sehen hier ist zu betonen
dass diese unterstützungskräfte sehr
wesentlich sind zb hier am beispiel der
fliegerabwehr nur durch effektive fliege
abwehr ist es möglich dass diese
privaten tatsächlich ihre fähigkeiten
entwickeln können
in den knapp drei monaten andauernden
konflikt wissen wir dass im wesentlichen
drei bereiche dazu beigetragen haben
dass die indischen streitkräfte solange
sich gegen die russische seite zur wehr
setzen konnte das eine war die taktik
war mit den ersten sechs wochen des
konflikts das zweite war die lieferung
von waffen vor allem hier vom panzer
bewachen aber auch flieger berling
waffen und das dritte war natürlich die
vermittlung von aufklärungsdaten diese
bereiche haben dazu beigetragen dass
wesentliche fähigkeiten gestärkt werden
konnten wie zum beispiel die
führungsfähigkeit der bereich der
aufklärung aber auch die angeblich kite
heute wollen wir uns nun ansehen ob die
lieferung von schweren waffen bis jetzt
bereits dazu beigetragen haben dass die
ukrainischen landstreitkräfte sich in
ihrer angriffs fähigkeit verbessert
haben oder nicht
dazu sehen wir uns als erstes an für den
bereich inkasso angriffs fähigkeit die
lieferung von kampfpanzern
bis jetzt war es möglich in die ukraine
knapp 100 kampfpanzer zu liefern aus
tschechien aus polen aber auch eine
gewisse anzahl aus bulgarien alle
systeme vom typ t 72 also systeme mit
dem die ukrainischen soldaten vertraut
sind
diese 100 fahrzeuge bilden im kern eine
verminderte panzerbrigade also knapp 2
panzerbataillone
schauen wir uns an die lieferung von
kampfjets und panzern oder gepanzerten
transportfahrzeugen auch hier ist es so
dass tschechien polen die niederlande
aber auch litauen fahrzeuge geliefert
haben zusammengerechnet ebenfalls knapp
über 100 stück was die ausstattung von
zwei bataillonen in einer verminderten
brigade darstellen würde
kommen wir nun zur artillerie- deren
bedeutung in den letzten wochen
besonders hervorgehoben worden ist hier
müssen wir unterscheiden zwischen
gezogenen geschützen und selbst so
lafetten bei den gezogenen die schützen
hat estland und bulgarien systeme
geliefert noch aus der zeit des kalten
krieges italien hat ebenfalls bereits
systeme vom kaliber 155 mm geliefert
bedeutungsvoll war aber natürlich die
lieferung des systems entwickeln durch
australien die usa und kanada insgesamt
circa 140 systeme was auch hier die
ausstattung einer verminderten atelier
brigade darstellen würde
sehen wir uns nun die selbstzahler
fetten haben auch hier wissen wir dass
polen und norwegen m109 derivate
geliefert hat auf der anderen seite
tschechien systeme vom typ tana aber
auch alte systeme vom typ 2 s 1
signifikant war die lieferung von zwölf
stück dieser der französischen
streitkräfte
das ist jenes system das bis jetzt das
potenteste am gefechtsfeld ist und auch
hier ist der große vorteil dass das
geschützt in der lage ist die russischen
streitkräfte über eine hohe distanz zu
treffen und dazu zeigen wir ihnen ein
kurzes video
wie stellt sich die situation bei den
mehrfach raketenwerfern da das war vom
system das auch sehr intensiv in den
letzten tagen und wochen diskutiert
worden ist hier ist die situation
tatsächlich sehr trist wir haben eine
lieferung von knapp 20 stück eines
tschechischen systems vom typ m 70 sowie
ebenfalls knapp 20 stück vom atp 21
beide systeme verschießen munition sowie
prominenz noch aus der zeit des kalten
krieges
wir haben die ankündigung auch der
lieferung von mehrfach raketenwerfer
system an das system heimat aber auch
das system mrs wenn man jedoch die
stückzahlen betrachtet nämlich vier
stück die aus den usa kommen sollen bis
27 die aus deutschland und aus
großbritannien kommen stellt sich die
frage ob diese geringe stückzahl
tatsächlich den erhofften effekt auf dem
gefechtsfeld bewirkt oder nicht
warum ist der artillerie nun so wichtig
da wesentliche hintergrund ist dass
beide seiten sich versuchen zu bekämpfen
außerhalb der reichweite der geschütze
der anderen seite man kennt ihr so gut
dass erst die lieferung von systemen aus
dem westen mit dieser panzerhaubitze
2000 die millionen geliefert werden soll
aber auch das französische system sicher
dass sich bereits im einsatz befindet es
den ukrainern möglich ist außerhalb der
reichweite der russischen geschütze
wirksam zu werden
noch viel effektiver stellt sich dass
dabei der lieferung von mehrfach raketen
werfer systeme wo die russische seite
vor allem durch das systems merck mit 70
kilometern im moment einen großen
vorteil hat und natürlich ist zu
betrachten die massive überlegenheit der
russischen artillerie gegenüber der
ukrainischen artillerie wie sich hier
diesem kommentar der washington post zum
ausdruck bringt
wenn wir uns jetzt die aktuellen
forderungen der ukrainischen seite
ansehen so sehen wir hier in diesem
twitter kommentar eines
regierungsberaters vom 13 juni 2022 dass
die ukrainische seite massiv
unterstützung mit schweren waffen
fordert nämlich über 1000 geschütze
gezogen oder auch selbst hätte über 300
mehrfach raketenwerfer über 500
kampfpanzer und über 2000 kam
schützenpanzer oder gepanzerte
transportfahrzeuge wenn wir so
vergleichen das was bereits geliefert
worden ist im gegensatz zur forderung
sehen wir wie groß der ablage
tatsächlich sich darstellt
wichtig ist zu verstehen dass die
ukrainischen streitkräfte vor zwei thema
dastehen das erste dilemma besteht darin
dass die russische seite seit dem 24
februar laufen in luftangriffen die
iranischen streitkräfte abnutzt selbst
der ukrainische präsident selensky geht
davon aus dass bis jetzt über 2.600
marschflugkörper aber auch ballistische
taktische raketen die iranischen
streitkräfte zunehmend abgenutzt haben
das heißt das problem ist dass dieses
arsenal an marschflugkörpern und
taktischen raketen entsprechend bekämpft
werden muss das heißt die bis jetzt
durchgeführten waffenlieferungen haben
so dazu geführt dass die bereichen
führungsfähigkeit aufklärung aber auch
an gerechtigkeit gestärkt worden sind
aber wesentliche andere fähigkeiten wie
zum beispiel der bereich schutz die
wurden nicht gestärkt was dazu führt
dass diese abnutzung der ukrainische
seite durch die russischen luftangriffe
laufend passiert um also das vermeiden
zu können würde man benötigen den
einsatz von getrennten flieger systemen
wie zum beispiel vom system ist 300 wo
wir hier kurz ein video zeigen
die herausforderung besteht darin
dass zwar die gelieferten westlichen
waffensysteme in den einsatz gebracht
werden können dort aber von den
russischen streitkräften aufgeklärt und
angegriffen werden können wie man das
zum beispiel hier kennt am beispiel
einer em triple seven batterie die
offensichtlich durch die russische seite
erfolgreich bekämpft worden ist die
zweite herausforderung besteht darin
dass die angelieferten waffensysteme in
die hände der russischen streitkräfte
fallen können dass dies der fall ist das
wissen wir bereits durch die lieferung
der leichten panzer warf oder flieger
bei lenkwaffen wo die russische seite
nicht wenige davon abhalten konnte und
nun selbst gegen die ukrainische seite
einsetzt auch dazu ein kurzes video
indem man erkennen kann das erbeutete
waffensysteme von den russischen
streitkräften eingesetzt werden
das zweite große thema das für die
iranischen streitkräfte besteht ist die
frage was soll mit den geheim kommen
geschehen waffensystemen getan werden
soll zusammen gewartet werden und es zu
einem geschlossenen einsatz kommen oder
sollen diese systeme sukzessive an die
front gebracht werden und dort
eingesetzt werden
die wichtigkeit dieser frage wird einem
bewusst wenn man die stückzahl der
angelieferten systeme betrachtet von der
deutschen bahn sowie 2000 sollen bis
ende juni zwischen sieben und elf stück
geliefert werden selbst von systemen
alter bauart wie diese tschechische 2 s
1 wurden knapp 20 stück geliefert die
frage ist wartet man zusammen und setzt
diese systeme geschlossen ein oder
schickt sie so wie sie kommen direkt an
die front
um die herausforderung der anlieferung
der schweren waffensystem wir besser zu
erklären habe ich hier noch zwei skizzen
vorbereitet die erste skizze sollen
ihnen zeigen die konkrete frage ob nach
der anlieferung der waffensysteme diese
zuerst bereitgestellt werden sollen in
der tiefe der front also zum beispiel
hier im raum person oder hier im raum
aktiv oder toolbars und ob nach einem
bereitstellen und zusammenführen der
kräfte es zu einem geschlossenen
massiven einsatz kommen soll im moment
sieht es danach aus dass die
angelieferten waffensysteme stückweise
in den einsatz gehen direkt an die front
womit sich die frage stellt ob sie dort
ihre tatsächliche wirkung entfalten
können das heißt wäre es nicht schlauer
ein privat wie weiland zusammenzufassen
und bahn anzugreifen oder so wie es
jetzt passiert die elemente die
hereinkommen stück für stück quasi an
die form zu verlegen ein gutes beispiel
dafür ist der von den ukrainischen
streitkräften durchgeführten angriff bei
person hier war es der fall dass eine
mechanisierte kampf gruppe versucht hat
gegen die russischen streitkräfte
vorzugehen wird auch in weiterer folge
eingekesselt und zerschlagen worden ist
auch hier ein kurzes video das den
einsatz dieser klinischen kampf gruppe
zeigt
wir wissen also dass die lieferung von
waffensystemen folgen von schweren
waffensystemen angelaufen ist wie man
also hier erkennen kann haben fast alle
europäischen staaten begonnen systeme zu
liefern und die frage die sich stellt
ist ob diese lieferungen rechtzeitig
kommen bzw ob sie auch richtig
eingesetzt werden zum schluss möchte ich
ihnen mit diesem bild zeigen dass die
anlieferungen von schweren waffen
systemen eine ganze reihe von
zusätzlichen herausforderungen mit sich
bringt dazu gehören nicht nur das
anliefern der waffen geschützt gegen zum
beispiel russische luftangriffe oder
auch die frage sollen sie stück für
stück in den einsatz gehen oder
geschlossen sondern es stellt sich vor
allem die frage der ausbildung hier in
diesem bild sehen wir die ausbildung von
ukrainische nationalisten angelieferten
norwegischen 109 system zusätzlich zur
ausbildung und zur qualität der
ausbildung ist auch die frage zu stellen
ob die richtige munition verfügbar ist
und auch in der richtigen anzahl um die
herausforderungen der ukrainischen
streitkräfte im osten entsprechend
bewerkstelligen zu können damit beende
ich meine vorrangig sagt herzlichen dank
fürs zuhören und bis zum nächsten mal